kamla's Defenders are saying that no one
can hold a candle candle to her as vice
president and now according to the New
York Post her Jasmine scented candles
bear her offices seal and they're even
being given out as gifts in California
Senator Alex Padilla wanted apparently
to do the same and asked the Creator to
produce 125 candles using the same scent
MH Harris's office then gave him
permission to produce a similar candle
but asked that he use a different scent
Jimmy we don't have priorities or
problems in the country but kamla has
the you know the candle crisis she is at
no and you got to be careful with the
kamla candle because one whiff and you
start laughing for no reason it's really
weird people just ask you questions I
obvious I obviously don't like the idea
of kamla passing out candles but it's
better than the time Bill Clinton passed
out cigars to the interns but let's tell
it like it is for a second this is
ridiculous and the idea that they
wouldn't give away the scent is just
like so emblematic of us fighting the
wrong battles who cares it's a candle
give them the candle Ingram that's what
I say well she's branding herself not as
a problem solver but a scent Defender so
um dollars and cents all right so faila
tell us about the show like yo what are
you going to do am I going to be invited
on like what's going to happen we is
there a is there a whole set involved
with a couch it looks like you were you
know kind of doing a PBS thing when I
saw that promo of you well yeah I'm the
only guy who gets thrown out of his own
promo commercial that was actually just
like real we were in the VIP area at a
club in Brooklyn but Fox News Saturday
night it is a cable news keg party as
you know Laura that's how this works
when you're a comedian okay if you're
hosting your own show you're doing your
own set at a club you're really not
there for the Republican Party of the
democratic party you're there for the
keg party so it's a Saturday night Solo
Cup where we are going to fire at
everyone except you and Hannity because
I was told my legs will be broken if I
insult either of you and that's fair
that's fair no keep it and see you in
Time Square not being mugged there
you're standing there and you're you're
actually not being mugged and you're
you're not being overwhelmed by some
food truck situation which is now it's a
big deal but now all the people I owe
money to know where to find me so I got
a problem here con congrats Jimmy we'll
be watching every Saturday at 10 p.m.
Eastern hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
will not get it anywhere
else